When you start talking about hope some people
think it’s immediately a kind of Pollyanna-ish
thing.
Like: “Oh, I should be hopeful,” or it’s
kind of a greeting card sentiment.
You go kind of doe-eyed and start thinking
soft thoughts about how we should all be hopeful
in one another.
And, of course, there are some important things
to be said in favor of those kinds of things,
but we think of hope as also an extremely
difficult and important and foundational sort
of state that can be discussed in ways that
aren’t so saccharine.
One of the interesting things that philosophers
talk about with respect to hope is, of course,
its rationality.
So there’s a sense in which you can’t
hope for everything.
You can wish for lots of things for which
you can’t hope.
I can wish that the Bears won the Super Bowl
last year, but I can’t hope that they won
the Super Bowl last year because we know that
they didn’t.
And so it seems almost like you’re misusing
the word to say, “I hope that they won last
year.”
Or, “I hope that the weather was different
yesterday than it was.”
So there’s a kind of semantic content that
suggests that there are rationality constraints
on hope which philosophers try to look at
and analyze.
There’s a kind of orthodox account—people
call it the orthodox account because most
people share it—that says that hope involves
at least desiring something and believing
that it’s possible.
So in this case you wouldn’t believe that
the weather yesterday could be different than
it was and so you wouldn’t believe that’s
possible, and so you can’t really hope for
it.
So that’s that condition that’s constraining
the rationality of hope.
And then there’s this kind of debate about
what further conditions might be required.
One thought experiment that people have discussed
frequently is that of 'The Shawshank Redemption'.
So this is a Stephen King short story that
was turned into a film.
You have two characters, Andy and Red.
Both of them really desire something: to get
out of prison.
Both of them regard it as possible, it’s
explicit in the story and in the film, but
somehow one character, Andy, is hopeful and
says he’s hopeful and that he’s acting
in such a way as to make it come about even
if he thinks it’s extremely unlikely.
And the other character, Red, says he can’t
allow himself to hope.
The fear of disappointment is too great and
will crush him.
So they both meet those conditions.
It’s something they really desire and it’s
something they believe to be possible, and
yet one hopes and the other despairs.
So cases like this make people think we need
some other kind of condition to really explain
the difference between hope and despair.
And that’s where some of the debate is at
the moment, trying to find this elusive third
condition.
And different people have different things
they want to add to the orthodox conception.
My own favored approach, which I’m in the
middle of writing up, is what I call the focus
or attention account of hope.
So it basically says something like the difference
between hope and despair is the extent to
which you’re focusing on the very slim odds
of the thing coming about or whether you’re
focusing on the fact that it’s possible—or
that you take it to be possible.
So if you’re focused on the thing as a possibility,
under the aspect of its possibility, if you
want, then you’re hoping for it.
If you’re focusing on the fact that it’s
incredibly unlikely and the odds are such
long-shot odds then you’re despairing of
it.
So you can desire it in the same way.
You can believe that it’s possible in the
same way.
And it’s this focus that really makes the
difference between hope and despair.
It might even be a kind of spectrum thing
where you can move back and forth.
The focus might be under your control sometimes,
other times given the circumstances or the
strength and the desire it might not always
be under your control.
So I also kind of talk a little bit about
the way a certain kind of mindfulness training
could lead us to be more hopeful people, cultivating
the virtue of hope by learning how to focus
on something under the aspect of its possibility
rather than allowing our focus or attention
to always drift towards the fact that it’s
so unlikely.
You can even hear this in the way that someone
might say something about what they hope for
or despair of.
So in the Andy and Red case, Andy might say,
“I know that it’s really unlikely but
at least it’s possible,” and sort of focus
on the possibility.
That’s the hopeful sort of approach.
And Red might say, “I know that it’s possible,
but it’s really unlikely.”
Same desire, same estimation of the probabilities
but you can even hear in the way it’s stated
a kind of difference in attitude that I take
to be the essential difference between hope
and despair.
So one more locus of discussion is the relationship
between hope, optimism, and action.
I think a lot of people regard hope in a way
as unserious because it gets detached from
action in a certain way.
So hope is something that you do when you
can’t do anything else.
It’s the kind of curse that is left in Pandora’s
box, because you still have it even though
there’s nothing else you can do with respect
to achieving the goal in question.
“I’m just hoping for it.
It seems possible but there’s not much I
can do.
I’m just sort of passively hoping.”
That obviously seems like a bit of a character
of the way in which hope might actually work.
And so we’re curious, and people in both
psychology and sociology, other social sciences
as well as philosophers and religious studies
people, in our project, think about the way
in which hope underwrites action, hope manifests
itself in action, hope is the result of action.
So agency and hope is a really interesting
set of issues that we think is underdeveloped.